I can imagine what can be and be
unburdened by what has been you know
all right people this is it the last
live Reuben report of the Year 2022
today is December 23rd and after we do
this show I release my workers to go
celebrate with their families enjoy
themselves eat some food
snuggle up do whatever they want and
then I'll see them next year and I'll
see you next year too fear not if you're
looking for some Video Entertainment
throughout Christmas week we've got a
couple best dubs and a bunch of fun
stuff that we'll be posting next week
but yes this is the last show for the
year uh and what a year it has been so
we are ending it with a Reuben report
locals Community Q a and I want to get
you guys caught up on a couple things
and we we have some major major major
major that's like five Majors stuff
coming up in 2023 and really as I've
said a couple times in the last few
weeks you know this has been the most
rewarding year of my life not only do we
have two sons now but the show has blown
up I feel like the pieces of my life
have come together I think probably more
than any other year in my 46 years on
this Earth my my personal life and my
career life have sort of lined up those
tracks are kind of working properly and
I'm working with the people I want to
work with and I'm doing the work work
that I want to do and I'm living in a
place that I want to live and I have the
family that I want to have and all that
stuff and and so much of that is because
of you guys and I'm I'm ever
appreciative of that and uh I'll say
some nice things at the end too but I'm
just uh I'm feeling the holiday spirit
right now and feeling the love and
sending it back to you guys through the
internet pipe so we're gonna do a
Community Q a it's a little bit
political a little bit personal a little
bit about the holiday in the future and
all that but before we get to the
Community Q a I do have an announcement
to make which is as you guys know over
the course of one year of living here in
Florida one of the things that I started
doing about a year ago was putting money
into this fancy plastic little container
here every time I gratuitously mentioned
California and we emptied this thing out
a bunch of times and there was a whole
bunch of five dollar bills in there and
it was adding up and adding up and
adding up and the idea behind that was I
was so sick of Cali and so loving the
freestyle Florida that I wanted to help
somebody else Escape I want to find a
refugee from Cali and help them move to
Florida to bask in the sunshine and the
freedom and all the wonderful things
that are happening here about halfway
through the year on a recommendation of
somebody we thought about flipping the
whole thing where instead of bringing
another person from California into
Florida although that is a lofty goal we
thought maybe we could just get rid of a
Democrat or a lefty from Florida and
move them out to California that started
started becoming very logistically
complex and ethically I didn't know if
it was totally right so we went back to
the original plan of at the end of the
year I was going to give a bunch of
money to help somebody move from Cali to
Florida and that is what I'm very
excited to announce uh today we had a
whole bunch of people all sorts of
people from all over not only America we
had people from other countries that
wanted to move to Florida but in the
locals Community people were commenting
people were recommending friends that
they wanted to to move her family
members or how we could help her et
cetera Etc it was tough to choose but
Kim K from California and as Phoenix
said to me right before he started do
you have to clarify it's not Kim
Kardashian there is another Kim K in
California uh you are the winner I'm
gonna email you personally after the
show today and you are the winner we
thought your story was the most
compelling you've got the six dogs and
cats the two 14 year old dogs we're
gonna get them cross country we're going
to help you out with the move and a
whole bunch more I'm going to give you
that cash and we'll we'll pay for some
other stuff and uh and you will bask in
the freedom of Florida and I'll have you
know what I'm going to take you out to
dinner too I'm going to take you out to
dinner once you're settled here and
maybe Clyde can meet all your uh all
your dogs so I'm very happy to be able
to help and uh and that's really the
spirit of the season and it's the spirit
of the show today but before we get to
the rest of the Community Q a I thought
how could we do do one story that would
really sort of personify
everything that this year was about sort
of the good stuff the bad stuff like is
there a way to do all of that in one
story and as you know one of the big
things that is happening at the end of
this year is that Anthony fauci Lord
fauci is stepping down which means that
hopefully in 2023 now that he's doing
this goodbye press tour for the last
couple weeks we basically won't hear
from this guy anymore that's really my
hope now I have no doubt that he will
somehow bubble out of the uh out of The
Ether again and he won't be fully done
but he will be done in terms of his
public facing covid uh front right so
there was a he's been doing all these
press hits we've shown you some clips of
some of them but he had this interesting
little snippet that I want to show you
this little snippet and then I want to
juxtapose it which is my word of the
Year juxtapose it with a little
something else so here's the first part
from Anthony fauci this is just this
week on how people feel about Anthony
fauci it's nice that some people you
know idolize me and put me up on a
pedestal but I don't get impressed by
that I never have
all right it's nice that some people
idolize them put them up on a pedestal
and okay he qualifies it with you know
I'm not that impressed so be it but that
first part that people idolize him they
put him up on a pedestal when he has
been so wrong about so many things and I
think that this was the year of 2022 was
the year of anything it was the year of
finding out that our experts were not
experts that our journalists were not
journalists that the truth tellers were
not truth-tellers that almost everything
was completely flipped on its head that
we worshiped people who did not deserve
worship and no human really deserves
worship that we we just got so much
wrong but within that we started
exposing some of the nonsense but the
reason I wanted to show you that clip
wasn't to bludgeon you with one more
Anthony fauci clip of the year it was to
compare it to juxtapose it with the
great Thomas Soul this is about 35 years
ago on the Charlie Rose show warning us
of people like Anthony fauci take a look
vision of the anointed self-tractor
congratulations is a basic for social
policy I mean you pause it here that
their group of self-anointed elitist um
who are responsible for what in America
well for much much of the social policy
of the past 30 years and for the
disastrous consequences that have fallen
from those policies and who are these
people well there'll be people in the
media in the academic world and in
politics uh particularly those who
believe that third parties can make
better decisions that people can make
for themselves and particularly when
they are those third parties uh I I
think most people who have not been in
the academic world would have to see the
academics in action to realize how
deeply they believe this I can remember
a conference at Middlebury College some
years ago yeah in which they were laying
out these plans for how they would
manipulate the poor in order to get them
to do this to do that to do the other
than I said who are we to be running
these people's lives and they looked at
me as if I were a man from Mars speaking
a language they had never heard before
that is my Christmas gift to you guys
Thomas so he is truly the gift that
keeps on giving but how good is that 35
40 years ago talking about the media the
academics and the politicians and that
they think they know better how to live
your life than you know how to live it
man was there ever in the history of the
world a better example of that than the
last couple years really 2020 and 2021
specifically but then the exposure of
their nonsense in 2022 and Anthony fauci
exemplifies that probably more than
anyone else instead of saying to people
hey you know look we we have some level
of understanding of what covet is but
you have to do what's best for you and
maybe you should work out a little bit
more because we know that obesity is a
comorbidity or you should get more
sunshine or more fresh air or you should
factor in your age or any of these other
things they just went all in on the
Draconian lockdowns and the school stuff
and the masks and and the vaccines that
don't work in the 18 times boosters and
all of that stuff and we should be we
should be uh not warned we should be
aware
we should be aware that this isn't the
first time it's happened and it ain't
going to be the last time and that's
exactly what Thomas soul is saying there
is this group of people that think they
know how everyone else should live and
call me crazy but like Thomas sold I
think you know how you should live your
life better than Anthony fauci or anyone
at Harvard Stanford or give me another
give me another elitist call Yale you
know the people at Yale they have to
talk like this did you know that they
have this thing where their mouth their
bottom jaw goes out like this when you
go to you
uh I think you know how to live your
life better than they know how to live
it for you so there you go I thought
that was just a nice sort of bow tie for
the rest of the year and hopefully that
2023 will be the year that regular
people realize hey you got a little skin
in the game and maybe it's your time to
shine and we should stop paying
attention to these charlatans and you
know self-proclaimed leaders and
elitists and everything else on that
note let's get to the Reuben report
Community Q a here we go Vince says what
is your favorite and most despised
Christmas song All right so everyone's
going to freak out I know you know we
don't get a lot of hate on this show
anymore years ago I used to get a lot of
hate I think over time people have
realized even the people that hate me I
think they've realized well you know
maybe I disagree with him but he's not
the worst guy in the world but I know
I'm going to get a lot of hate for this
one my my most hated
Christmas song Believe It or Not is All
I Want For Christmas Is You by Mariah
Carey now okay I got it Connor's
freaking out Phoenix won't even look at
me I get it I get it people love the
song it's got a tune It's gotta beat
Mariah Carey 90s it's all kind of
working so you're going Dave how do you
not like that song how do you hate that
Christmas song
in uh in 1998 when I got out of college
my first job I've mentioned this on the
show before I don't like to brag about
it was I was assistant manager of
Electronics Boutique which is now known
as GameStop in the Broadway Mall in
Hicksville Long Island okay I was moving
more Pokemon Red than anybody back in
98. and during Christmas season when you
work in a mall they play that song
50 60 200 times a day
it is on Non-Stop there's nothing you
could do about it it's in you it's in
your ears it's in your mouth it's in
your pores you hear it over and over and
over again you leave them all you're
with CR you're with Mariah Carey she's
sitting in the car with you you turn on
the radio it's back on the song started
making me crazy I couldn't take it
anymore you understand I don't know why
I feel like I'm Regis Philbin now okay
it was making me nuts
so I just can't hear it anymore I just
can't so that's that and I'm sorry
the song that I like the most though my
favorite uh Christmas song of all time
uh without question is Have Yourself a
Merry Little Christmas by The One and
Only Frank Sinatra I know there's many
versions of it right who do we say sang
it for the person who's Judy Garland
around 1944 but Frank Sinatra's version
of it which I'm guessing was probably
from probably early 60s something like
that it's just perfection I just love
Frank Sinatra in general so just perfect
so there you go I hope that you know I
wouldn't lose a lot of subscribers on
this last show with my my slandering of
Mariah Carey Lewin says will the Twitter
files make any kind of dent in the
mainstream totalitarian narrative or
will all these threads just wind up in
the stinking heap of the but look at
their crimes pile it's a great question
it's something that I've tried to
address a lot lately like this
Divergence in reality where a whole
bunch of people are saying wow there's
really something here we have the
evidence of collusion between government
and big Tech not only do we have the
evidence I mean the government literally
was paying Twitter to remove content
millions and millions of dollars we know
that for sure no one is doubting whether
that is true people are ignoring it if
it goes against their narrative it's not
something you're going to see on CNN but
there is no legit person that is denying
that the emails that that Elon has
allowed to uh escape from from the
internal Twitter stuff that he has sent
to some of these journalists
nobody's doubting that this stuff is
true that being said there's always
going to be a certain amount of people
that ignore it or don't see it or some
combination thereof and then really what
gets the heart of your question is it's
like but things don't seem to change
right it seems like we we expose stuff
we find out more we know that these
people are acting immorally and
potentially criminally but nothing
really changes so I don't want to be
pollyanish and tell you that that
everything is going to change because of
this stuff but what I do think has
happened this year and that that is the
beauty that I hope 2022 will be
remembered by which is sort of what I
referenced earlier that the the
charlatans and the people who lied about
everything a certain amount of people
did wake up to that now you can't wake
up everybody but more people did wake up
and the world's richest man who did not
have to do this did it and he exposed a
lot of this nonsense that will inspire a
lot of people that'll that'll Inspire
also the right type of people people who
will build businesses who will build
Industries who will build new
technologies etc etc so I don't know
that the government specifically will do
something about it I'm I'm somewhat
hopeful that the Republican Congress can
do a little bit of something but I'm not
I'm not sitting here like oh my God the
Republicans are going to save us because
obviously they often will fail us more
than they will not fail us but I think
there is a chance so we shall see uh
Vaughn says how wrong do you think Bruce
Willis is when he said Die Hard is not a
Christmas movie did Bruce Willis
actually come out and say that die hard
is absolutely a Christmas movie I don't
know how many times I have to say it and
how any you know everybody says it die
hard is a Christmas movie I understand
it's not the most cheery Christmas movie
of all but it takes place on Christmas
nakatomi Tower Christmas music The
Beautiful Love Story between Bruce
Willis and the father from Family
Matters what was his name Reginald Bell
Johnson okay wow that's a reference uh
it's a Christmas movie I mean Christmas
party it's a Christmas party that the
hostages are taken uh taken at you know
the guy doing coke who's blown you know
gets his brain blown out by uh what's
his name who is in Harry Potter you got
it okay prusky says why is it okay for
people like Chuck Schumer to incite
violence or threaten the president of
the United States and not be held
accountable I mean look you're you're
asking me that million dollar question
that you know we've played these
compilation videos of Maxine Waters
getting their face and AOC protesters to
make people uncomfortable and when Chuck
Schumer has done it too they they all
can do this and what I would say is
it's Democrat privilege man that's what
it is it's Democrat privilege they are
allowed because they they go towards the
system or they go to higher taxes they
go to they want centralized power so the
system will encourage you and it will
help you do that when you go down the
other path and you say I'm not that
interested in the system I don't like
top-down view of the world all those
things the system is less kind to you if
you just take a moderate deviation off
what the system wants it'll call you far
right and a scary mean conservative and
an evil Republican and a racist and a
transfer been a bigot
so they they will always have more of a
leash on that stuff but again it's it's
sort of like the first question it's
like just start seeing it start seeing
it start being part of this wake up that
is happening across the country
um and and maybe in your own life you
can figure out ways to to not be so
beholden to people who are not good and
I would put Chuck Schumer in that bucket
uh Ben says now that we're at a point
where Americans cannot even agree on the
oldest Foundation of human understanding
that being defining a man and a woman
which is a tricky one it is clear that
the political Echo chambers that we live
in have taken us into dangerous
territory as a country how do you
realistically see this panning out P.S I
bought my first bottle of Claus Azul and
I love it man isn't there is nothing
like it we knocked out you know how many
bottles of classical we knocked out at
the Holiday party we knocked out
probably 10 bottles of that stuff it
ain't cheap but it's all right it's all
right I'm happy to do it for you guys
um well first off I'm very happy that
you're on the closet as well it's just
it'll change your life it's just great
um I assume you're getting the reposado
because the other ones are crazy except
for the blanco the rest ones are crazy
expensive but if you got if you got like
one of those black bottles man you Savor
that I'm talking a sip that's it you got
to savor that for a long time
um
how do we how do we get past
this stuff I mean look we got this this
Divergence as I'm talking about all the
time and it's like how do we bring some
of it back together I mean it's cliche
but the truth will set you free I think
if we're a little bit better than the
other guys if we're a little bit less
hysterical if we can calmly explain to
people you know boy years later sure you
were yelling at me for not getting facts
and you wanted me to be fired from my
job and have my kids taken away and kill
my dog and all that stuff but you know
what are you gonna do you want to make
up like if we can just be a little bit
better because the the thing is not
gonna stop the woke thing yes we can
expose it and it feels like it's losing
momentum in a certain way and all of
that stuff but at some level it's never
going to stop and I think maybe this is
why this is why it's very hard it's much
harder for conservatives to conserve
things than for say leftists to
liberalize things to conserve something
you got to go man people before me built
something and I have to protect that
thing right I've to do my best to
protect it and honor it and and you may
view it as something that is imperfect
but it's like boy human evolution sort
of got us to this thing that's that's
good let's say the United States the
principles that that you and I believe
in this is a good thing we got to
protect that thing holding on to that
thing while everybody's trying to get it
and destroy it and take it out the
Socialists the marxists the Communists
all the it's much easier to burn things
down so that's why it seems like things
are always sort of devolving because to
to live in a time when people are really
building that's that's special and
Transcendent by the way it's happening
in certain places have I mentioned
Florida like it's happening right here
the the the building of a future America
it really really is and I have no doubt
that it's happening in other uh parts of
the country as well and it might be
happening just in your home or in your
local community but it is way easier
just to look at someone else's work just
to look at the fruits of someone else's
labor and shred it and destroy it and
burn it and and there is a uh I would
say a nihilistic attitude for a certain
set of young people it might have
something to do with purely growing up
on screens and in the in in the
craziness of social media uh that they
seem to want to burn a lot but it is our
job to make sure that not everything
gets burned uh Batista says what new
holiday traditions do you have or you're
hoping to start this year well
right now as we as we do this we're in
night five or six or so of Hanukkah and
for the first time on night one of
Hanukkah we had the kids we had the
menorah we had the candles we we said
the prayers we lit the candles uh I
tried to explain the uh the story of
Hanukkah to Justin he was drooling all
over the place not really paying
attention so I would imagine over a
couple years we can get into that The
Maccabees the Greeks were here today in
Hills I could have him watch my video
with Netanyahu who's a fairly good
explainer of uh of History uh but yeah I
would say connecting back to uh to some
of those Traditions is something that we
will we will take with us and I think
it's partly uh you feel more in uh that
it's more incumbent upon you to do that
I think that when you have kids rather
than when you're just sort of an adult
floating around in the universe Naomi
says what is your favorite Christmas
movie it is without question Christmas
Vacation Chevy Chase whip out oh I got a
nod on that one okay you weren't happy
on Mariah Carey it's without question
Christmas vacation I think it's a great
even if you remove the other Vacation
movie bees Beverly D'Angelo the whole
you know the kids that are always
rotating and all that you forget the
first movie which is fantastic second
one's not great but uh just on its own
Christmas vacation is just a great movie
it's like it's like Prime cheby Chase
and just the silly little uh like all
the his little mumbles and words and
that's just it's just perfect and all
like the family stuff and the in-laws
come in the fighting and that but they
all come together at the end and it
works out so there you go Christmas
vacation without question I would say
die hard number two because I do count
it as a Christmas movie Nick says
assuming that the timeline would remain
stable and that your life right now
would remain unchanged without a
Flashpoint Paradox lordy lordy where are
we going with this uh what is one thing
that you would tell childhood Dave if
you had the opportunity
to travel back in time man we're going
deep at the end of the year
um
I guess something like uh it's gonna be
all right I guess something like that
like I guess if I was to look at my life
now at 46 like it's pretty good it's
pretty all right you know it's it's
pretty I don't know that it's going to
get much better than this and that's
actually quite all right like it's it's
good I've got a good family I've got a
good extended family I do work that's
valuable I work with great people all of
those things like I wake up every single
day I never let's put it this way I
never wake up and be like why what am I
going to do today or whatever it is that
I have to do is something that I don't
want to do like I wake up every day with
like a sense of purpose and a reason to
be there with things to do and a
freaking calendar that is that is
jam-packed you know basically from
morning to night and all of that stuff
um so my life is very very full so what
would I say
yeah that it's going to be okay I think
I had a lot of years especially late mid
to late 20s into a good portion of of
the early 30s and and maybe even mid
where it was very tenuous at best I had
successes as a stand-up and I had
failures I had tried tried these jobs
that jobs I did all sorts of odd I've
done every waiting tables and being a
bartender and handing out tickets on
Comedy Club streets and working at a PR
firm and I did all of this stuff and it
was always with this like goal in mind
that I was going to be something
something kind of like I guess I turned
out to be but I didn't even know what it
was and there were a lot of times I
would say the first 10 years I never
once thought of quitting even when it
sucked and I was broke and I was
literally eating tuna every night
because I had a buddy in Food Service
who would drop off industrial sized cans
of tuna to my Apartments just so I could
survive
um but I never thought of quitting and
then I think maybe late 20s early 30s
like when it when it started getting
leaner and my friends had families and
houses and all that stuff and I was like
scratching for anything
there were definitely times that I
thought I could quit and I or that I
would quit and I was like man I gave
this everything I got and is it possible
that you could give something everything
you got and it won't work out but I even
through that I just kept going and I
think the lesson that I've learned now
is that if you give
something everything you got
you may not get exactly what you wanted
but you will get something in that
approximate Direction and I think that
that is what this is an example of so I
would have just said hey Dave just chill
out a little bit it's going to be all
right uh little red sailboat says Dave
and team thank you for all your hard
work and great content your common sense
and humorous delivery helped lower my
blood pressure and keep me grounded glad
to hear that in particular it's our
tax-funded Public Schools spending
precious classroom time on radical
ideologies that make my blood boil can
you give us three tips to practice on
how to remain calm when discussing
radical ideologies that have sneaked
their way into the Elementary classrooms
you know this is a good question to get
this week because the week started by me
going to the freedom blueprint
conference with Governor DeSantis where
he sat down with it was probably I don't
know about 300 people that are current
school board members or running for
school board positions or are
superintendents or just running within
the system to clean up the system and
you know Florida we obviously have a
pretty good situation here because of
the governor because of our Mayors where
we've removed a lot of the wokeness out
of the school but it out of the schools
but it still is in some places we happen
to do this in Orlando Orlando is still a
bit of a blue pocket in a very red state
so there are people that are still
fighting the woke stuff the race stuff
the gender stuff it's even here
um I don't know about three tips but
I'll give you one tip I give this one
all the time about be a little bit
better right so like it's just like
they're going to be hysterical don't be
hysterical but I think another one and I
I said it if you watch my uh my 20 or 30
minute video the speech that I gave at
the conference it's something that I
said it's like you got to think about
how things have changed and really think
about how they have changed and and have
they changed for the better and I asked
the crowd I said everyone pick picture
your I think I did this on the show a
couple weeks ago too right I said
everyone picture your third grade
teacher picture you in third grade
you're down here now picture your third
grade teacher my third grade teacher was
this woman Mrs kochenauer I love this
lady she used to read us the secret
garden and she would do all the voices I
I just absolutely adored her I thought
she was 160 years old in retrospect she
was probably only 50 or something that
seemed very old to me at the time but I
love this woman now imagine this woman
who was I guess 55 probably
and out of nowhere been like David David
let's talk about sex and gender and
let's do it quietly and keep it quiet
and I'm gonna call you Daphne could we
do that can we like it's so bananas that
that would have happened when I'm
growing up back in the 80s yet it is
almost routine now right it is happening
all across the country now so I think if
you calmly explain that to somebody like
do you really think that is good if they
have kids a really good way to do it do
you honestly believe that it would be
good even if your child was confused
about their gender or sexuality or any
of this and by the way no third grader
is no because no third graders thinking
about this [ __ ]
but do you really think it would be good
or just or legal or moral for a state
employee to talk about those issues to
your child potentially call them another
name
not disclose it to you do you really
believe that and by the way you will be
disappointed because you will get some
people who will say yes but they don't
really mean it in their heart they mean
it through their brainwashed lens and if
you just put it back on them put it back
on them you know it could be anything uh
it could be about about the welfare
state do you think that if you were
given money to do nothing that you would
turn it away and go bust your ass or do
you now see how that would create a
cycle of poverty like I think that's the
best way to do it to really personalize
it for these people but it is tough it
is tough Tony says can we get a Reuben
report Community Meetup in Florida soon
to celebrate All of Us escaping to the
land of Freedom yes we are working on it
uh we'll probably do it somewhere in
South Florida most likely Miami area but
I've got a couple locations that I think
will be good we will do that for the uh
for the locals Community I'll buy some
drinks we'll have a good time and we
will celebrate freedom here in Florida
Margot says hey Dave we all love your
shows here all right thank you very much
uh I think you know this by now any
chance you could insert some really true
feel-good stories in your shows I mean
there are some really great humanitarian
people in the world doing wonderful
things for others and we don't hear
about them often enough I actually love
that idea it's something we've discussed
a little bit
because you know how I feel about the
the racehorse politics stuff right it's
why over the last two months really post
midterm elections I've really focused on
the culture stuff as opposed to every
little bit of political machinations
that are happening everywhere
um but the idea of focusing on people
that are doing good things in their own
communities yeah maybe we'll do like a
monthly Roundup I got the I got the nod
from Phoenix we will do some kind of
monthly Roundup or maybe like mini Skype
interviews with people and Shine the the
spotlight on good people doing good work
because they are out there uh Kathy says
can you announce anything exciting
happening on the Rubin report for 2023
so there's a bunch of stuff that we've
sort of been sitting on for for a bit
that I think I'm going to hold a bit
longer and make some announcements in
2023 I will tell you this is a little
bit of a tease as you know I started
locals uh you know at this point it's a
good four four years ago or so five
years ago almost with the idea of like
can I do something to to fight this big
Tech Madness and clearly uh big Tech
Madness needed to be fought and then
about a year ago we merged with Rumble
we don't know it's hard to fight a
battle alone right you like to be with
some teammates that have some other
weapons so you can fight in many ways
you got your your Air Force and your
Navy and your army and all that stuff
and that's how you that's really how you
go on this battle and that is what we're
in uh so we will be expanding on our
partnership uh with Rumble and with
locals we're going to be adding a daily
locals component to the show so I will
at least tell you that much going
forward so starting in 2023 3 when we
finish the live show which will remain
here on Rumble and on YouTube just as
you see it normally we'll continue for
about a 15-minute post game show where
we'll take some questions that I told
the guys I want them to correct me if I
screwed anything up like we're gonna
make it more fun and kind of silly and
relaxed and uh and all that stuff that's
one little thing we're going to be doing
and then we'll have some other
announcements along the way but uh but I
can tell you this also 2022 is by far
our biggest year we crushed every number
across every platform every month
basically was our biggest month in terms
of every metric that you can possibly
imagine
and uh and it's all good and it's
because of you guys and I thank you for
it and and again we're right back at the
beginning uh Benjamin says do you any
suggestions on how to begin to Red Pill
someone
booze class Azul a little tequila
usually helps um
well it's a little bit of what I said
earlier about you know you turn some of
this stuff make it real personal for
them make them really think how they
would behave in a specific situation
whether it was relative to their kids or
or their dollars instead of just sort of
the amorphous tax dollars that kind of
thing but I think I really really think
the way to Red Pill people is to live a
good life that really is it more than
anything else people people inherently
know a certain set of things the the
walksters are so hysterical they're so
angry they're so mean their their whole
world is wrapped up in so many lies it's
why Democrat politicians when I show you
these videos of Karin Jean-Pierre it's
why she can't say a word of Truth a word
of truth they're so in on that thing and
it's so inauthentic it's what I always
said about trump it was like you may not
like Trump but Trump was more authentic
than every one of these Democrats
obviously you may not like certain
things about him but but authenticity
matters and I think if you authentically
live a good life like somewhere in the
ballpark as close to good as you can get
and you just keep trying to get there
and sometimes you'll you'll fall off
that wagon and you'll have to get back
on it and all of those things
then over time it shows somebody who
might be on the fence boy do I go full
woke or do I go sane
you know that's the choice and they
might look and be like boy those again I
don't like that conservative thing but
like those people over there they're
they're actually all right and that's
one of the things that worked for me it
wasn't just the idea set it's that when
I started talking
not just talking to I mean on the show
but when I started hanging out and
having dinners with Glenn Beck and and
Jordan obviously and Ben Shapiro and
Dennis Prager and all these people it
wasn't just that the idea set was good
and they wanted to talk about it was
like they were nicer
really I mean that more generous of
spirit and kind and all of those things
and I think that ultimately is how you
get people over Sweetwater says what is
an unexpected trait about David that you
love unexpected that's tough unexpected
I mean we've been together for for 13
years which for straight people it's
like 40 years or something so it's hard
to get me uh something that's unexpected
um he has been an absolutely phenomenal
father like phenomenal father you know I
work I'm in here doing my thing and
traveling a bit and
focused on the show and the ideas and
all of these things for many many hours
a day David is down there with two kids
you know basically four months and two
months who are at various stages of
development right now and as as they get
older you know two months which two
months right now means a lot but as they
get older it'll kind of lock up and
they'll in essence be twins and then
hopefully you know emotionally they're
roughly the same they meant I don't mean
their temperament will be exactly the
same but like the ballpark they're going
to eat at the same time and they'll be
able to poop by themselves and a bunch
of other stuff
um he's down there like running the show
down there uh you know basically 24
hours a day and he has absolutely
thrived and found purpose in it that
made my life easier along the way and
you know eat every day if I finish a
show I get to go down there and I play
with the kids quick and maybe I'll
change a diaper quick and then I get
back up here and do my thing and all
that but I can't say that's unexpected
because uh because he's good he's really
good and I know how badly he wanted this
and and now he's living the the reality
that he was fighting for so so it's not
unexpected but it is certainly good uh
t-mod says I've been a new Floridian for
almost a year now Christmas here is much
better in Tampa than in the San
Francisco Bay Area people are friendly
believing in God and being a
conservative in California was a harder
job than I thought do you agree that
people are more friendly and accepting
here in Florida well this is the final
question of the year
and it's a good one yeah
yeah because when you set
the ground for Freedom when you when you
do the work on the ground the soil is
Rich and then good things can grow out
of that the amount of holiday spirit
that I see here in my community here in
Miami is so much more than what I saw in
my community la
uh October the Halloween spirit like
every house here was doing awesome stuff
but it's not just that it's the
neighbors saying hi the smiles the how
you doing the saying hi to the babies
the restaurants that are packed like the
life that is here and then you see all
the refugees people come here I still
see this now people that I know that
live in Cali come and they visit and
they cannot believe it and then when
I've gone back the other way I'm like I
can't believe this that people still
live like this so if you create the
conditions for freedom and you vote the
right people in who will Who will
protect those things
um it's not just an academic exercise of
like we live freely our schools teach
the right things
it's something that starts bursting out
of you which is that humans want
connection they want to be social not
anti-social they want to not be staring
at this all the time but looking out and
about it also helps that the weather
here is great so you know if you if you
live up in New York let's say or in a
really cold place during Christmas it's
nice because of snow this time of year
and everything else but like you're
usually kind of running in and out to
get you know back into the heat indoors
we're here it's like I'm outside in a
t-shirt right now feeling good like
there's more people out there's just
there's just a sense of life that is
good so congratulations on moving from
you know dystopian San Francisco to free
Florida and on that note once again I
want to congratulate Kim K not Kim
Kardashian
uh but a different Kim K we are going to
get you out of Cali we're going to move
you to Florida and see how else we can
help and I'm very excited for you and
the cats and the dogs and the whole
thing I assume there's some birds and
hamsters who knows what you got very
excited uh on that note guys that is our
last show of 2022 in case it is not
clear I uh I am appreciative and I am
humble in my thank you to all of you
guys for making this our most successful
year ever on on every front and in every
metric possible uh it has been an
absolute blast I think this is just the
beginning you know there's so many
things happening in the world that are
so connected to all of the stuff that we
talk about whether it's whatever is
going to happen in 2024 and how Florida
will be directly connected to that or
whether it's the Free Speech stuff or
just any of the stuff that we talk about
here uh these these things are real and
if I've moved the dial in just a tiny
way and affected you in some way that
made your situation and a little bit
better or made you think about any of
this stuff a little bit clearer than
that is pretty freaking awesome
I'd also like to thank this guy Connor
over here and this guy Phoenix over here
we really did something special this
year in this room Daphne's in here
sometimes but these are my two main guys
in here every day and we created I walk
in here and it's like we're good we're
laughing we're having fun and I think
that translates into why you guys
probably watch the show so I thank you
as I said we'll have some announcements
oh and I guess I can tell you one other
thing for now which is that we will do
our first show of 2023 uh we'll be in
studio here on uh on January 2nd and
then that night I'm heading up to
Tallahassee it's the governor's
inauguration so I will be there for the
ball that night and then there's a bunch
of events the next day so we'll do a
quick pre-tape for the third and then
I'm going to try to tape a bunch of
stuff there maybe I can get the governor
but there's going to be a whole bunch of
other people there and what a beautiful
way to kick off the year right like what
a beautiful way to kick off 2023. I am
very excited about that on that note
thank you guys Happy Hanukkah merry
Christmas happy New Year enjoy yourself
enjoy your families love each other all
the stuff the TV personalities say when
they sign up for the year and we leave
you for the last time in 2022 with the
elderly man pretending to be president
goodbye I may be Irish but I'm not
stupid
I married Dominic giacopa's daughter so
you know I got a little Italian to me
now you know